see web now kind of have to call into
the program how are you Chris hey I'm
doing fine I mean the Warriors are
unlike anything I've ever seen I wonder
what you think about him oh man there's
something special and I think this
reminds us that it is the core of curry
Thompson and Rima that's that's why
special yesterday added another MVP and
they have the unique position of having
two MVPs on that team but as we see with
one of the greatest players in the
league it's not the best plan to lead
Kevin Durant out that what made them so
great was their style of play their ball
movement including everyone making every
playable valuable valuable on the floor
as long as they understood their lanes
and the role players are some of the
best role players and definitely the
star specifically dream on curry and
Thompson there's a special to watch I
don't even know how you beat him Chris I
mean you're seeing the two teams that
are vying for the right to answer that
question seeing what those guys can do
and knowing what the Warriors are doing
tell me how they get beat you get beat
with answer the kupo you get beat with
you know it is funny and in all my years
and I've been around the league about
and now about 27 years I've never seen
an East Coast team play fast place and
play West Coast basketball I've never
seen it never seen a coach have the
nerve to try to implement it I've never
seen the team have the skill players to
try to do it and right now the Bucs are
playing with the fastest pace of any
team in the playoffs in the last 20
years so they get up and down they play
a little bit of old school because they
score a ton of points inside they shot
and made the second most amount of
threes in the league and and again
they're playing fast place and they play
with defense and so this is special what
we're watching but as we've seen
the press conferences after they talk
about how special it is to get to five
they remind us that it's not about
making it to five it's about winning
when you get there and so they
understand that all this is fine and
dandy but it could be ended abruptly by
a team like the books even though you
know most people will say it's not
likely as still as the league and you
still have an MVP candidate answer the
coop all west coast coach and coach bud
and guys that can get it done and so
hopefully you have guards that can make
shots that can put pressure on the
Golden State guards and then hopefully
you have a star that can close and you
have some shooters around you and not
that this series is over yet but they're
looking at a team like the books you
know it would be still a good series do
you think they need durant in order to
win it on yes why do you say that
Durant's the best player in the world
and even though we've seen this great
plan this has been remarkable this is
still a small sample size against the
team that they swept years ago that they
swept last year so do not get it twisted
they would not have won last year
without Durant by no stretch of the
imagination in with the game seven and
Houston not to miss 27th the reason a
row because Durant when others aren't
scoring or going to a slump he's he's
he's all great fixer he's the one that
separates herself from everyone with
this efficiency his height is shooting
and being able to post up guards then
can't keep going at curry as they do
because they have to watch out for
Durant so no they they need all hands on
deck to win this championship because
they're still a team is still not about
those three guys that I keep bringing up
they are the core in the heart so but
they need other players to get it done
Chris whoever turned sports here on the
Rich Eisen show it seems to mean again
this may be just a knee-jerk reaction
over the last five games having heard
him wired for sound and I know you and
Reggie talked about it on the Turner
broadcasted on a microphone that ESPN
and ABC's microphones picked up from
draymond Green talking to Jordan Bell
that that greens maturity has caught up
with his ever burgeoning game what do
you think Chris
no this is a witness has always always
been we just got to hear it that's
officially was five years ago I'm no and
remonstrance high school I've admired
his game his heart very close with Coach
Izzo we talked about dream on a lot no
this is who he is
we just had some great guys on the mic
and and they called a Clemson allowed
the world to see a glimpse of who he is
but this is that that's who he's been
the old-time inconsistent if if he
wasn't that way his teammates were
playing with him and so his teammates
wouldn't like playing with them and they
love playing with them because this is
what we've seen so a lot of times in
sports whatever the narrative is from
the major media a lot of us in the
locker room laugh because we know what
those guys are and a lot of times those
guys don't want to share the sense or
how um how encouraging and things like
that they are because it's really no one
else's business but them and the guys on
the team so if it wasn't for a dunk
missed and in a play like that we would
not forgot to see the compassion and the
will of dream on so that that happens a
lot and no it's not more maturity it's
just it's just to either so if he cusses
out the rant in a couple weeks it's not
a real absences well then I guess maybe
I chose a the wrong example then to ask
the question he says that he realized
over the last couple weeks that he's
doing more crying than playing
basketball and decided to - he even said
that he'd changed something or at least
an approach Chris Oh last couple weeks
cuz he was crying more than the normal
but he'll get back to crying he cried a
lot last night and he'll get back to it
but knows it's not a graduation it's not
okay you know he went to counseling is
he knows himself and he knows that
sometimes it's better for him to be a
jerk and then he knows that sometimes I
better come back and balance that for
guys on my team so totally totally
understands Chris whoever here on the
Rich Eisen show from Toronto alright
let's let's talk a little bit of raptors
in tonight's game Chris your your cont
your concern level força wise
health is what well first I just like to
say this because last year I got dogged
a lot because I'm very close with coach
Popovich and Kauai and I hated the
narrative that Kauai quit so for
everyone that said last year he quit and
that he didn't have heart and that he
wasn't a great teammate because he
didn't talk and spill his soul out to
the media I hope that you're eating your
words right now secondly Kristen Ledlow
did an interview with him after the game
and one coach told me that he's playing
on one leg and he said everybody's hurt
this year and he didn't embellish and he
didn't take a knee and act all tired
like some players may do when they
fought through adversity and so number
one I love the consistency of him when
he's hurt he's not going to talk about
it and when he hits you with 35 points
and dunks and steals and hobbling on one
leg he doesn't embellish and so on I'm
glad for him that hopefully all the
critics have been silenced about the
nonsense that they were talking last
year just trying to take the side of a
coach that they never met before and so
I'm happy about that but I still think
it's about the bench man when you look
at the bench of this Toronto team the
question has been who's going to step up
you know choir is going to play well but
if it wasn't for Norman Powell how he
came in and played and you know with
this team being you know in that
position so I'm looking for Ramsey you
know where where is he in the regular
season the average 11 and this series
he's averaging four he's only he's been
three for 25 and 3 pointers from the
last 10 games so where is he Danny Green
you know everybody skips over him he's a
starter he only had three points and was
one for nine he started over eight the
other night and so in this series he's
four for 14 you know you need guys to
step up and so for me Kauai has been
that constant especially on both ends of
the floor but it really doesn't matter
if he if he doesn't get any help you
know they can go home pretty soon if
those other players don't step up couple
topics outside of the playoffs Chris
before I let you go if you don't mind
frank vogel introduced as what everybody
here in town clearly knows wasn't the
first choice to be the head coach of the
Los Angeles Lakers and that happens on
the day that Magic Johnson goes on first
take and torches the Lakers like it's
King's Landing what do you think LeBron
is thinking this very morning Chris I
think things probably make a little more
sense to him that you know magic didn't
quit on the team but his magic wasn't
allowed to do what he was brought in to
do and he doesn't have time to sit
around and be a figurehead i I don't
think magic really destroyed the Lakers
I think he told us what's going on there
and for a lot of us we understand what
players and people in basketball that
don't care about the outcomes think of
the Lakers and I'm not just saying that
a somebody that went through the Lakers
or played against them I've been a Laker
fan my whole life and and so you're kind
of you know you're kind of seeing the
truth I mean I think it's just that
simple
why wouldn't you have Magic David we'll
make decisions why wouldn't you hire
tyloo because the optics don't look good
when you got LeBron you knew that you
were going to probably have to hire a
guy that he likes what's wrong with that
you'd do the same for Brady if he didn't
have double check you know you always
try to find a quarterback a quarterback
coach and so anytime you're in a
situation where you hire the coach from
the Sacramento Kings and they didn't
make the playoffs and you're talking
about free agents or something like that
and then you're misleading yourself
you're just stuck in you're stuck in a
narrative that everybody wants to go to
LA like they can't live there in the
summer and that they want to take on the
Beast of the media and the pressure and
have that be thrust upon them without
the responsibility being thrust
throughout throughout the organization
so I think it's the truth and it's what
a lot of us already kind of you know
kind of thought that was going on in
there and I know magic smiles and tend
to think he's a nice guy or aloof but
he's part of the joke he knows he knows
what's going on and once he couldn't be
part of the remedy
I see why I see why you got the hell out
of Dodge
what were you gonna put you're gonna
shoot him and not let him make any
decisions he reminds me of the old
football saying if you're gonna what it
Parcells says and whether Parcells or
who who said that our energy to cook
without right doing a little shopping
and getting your own groceries and so
yeah Frank Vogel is not the guy that
free agents are gonna come looking
forward to play for from his time in
Indiana to his time in Sacramento it's
it's he's a good coach but we're talking
about super free agents and the fact
that everything has to be right to try
to recruit them and the fact he came
from a losing team and basically
Sacramento in LA switched coaches that
that doesn't do much for the narrative
or the story to make anyone enthusiastic
and it's not Coach Vogel's fault it's
just all the talk that was done before
then well I mean the you know I hear you
on the on the why not hire a guy for
LeBron statement I do want to also a
little bit coach no you're right yeah I
just I do want to offer a little bit of
pushback on on the other part of it
we're magic when he said goodbye in some
there's no other way to put it strange
bizarre press conference that even
LeBron on his HBO show was questioning
about giving getting zero heads-up on
from magic he didn't say at the time I
wasn't allowed to make my choice he said
I wanted to fire Luke and I just don't
have that's not who I am I'm not the guy
who fires people you know or alters
families like that and now to come out
on first take the day that Vogel is
announced and I know that that was
apparently pre-arranged it just it was a
different story Chris that that was the
thing that was left me scratching my
head yesterday I don't know if it was a
different story or if he just stopped in
frustration first of all that let's be
honest that that was not a good look
that you would quit and not tell Jenny
bus so I'm not absolving him in any of
the way that anything was expressed
right and the interview yesterday was
plans he had a pre plan but I think what
happened was that he tried to quit and
get away from it and everyone kept
dragging him down and saying while magic
quit and did this and did that and then
he had to come back and say okay y'all
want the truth well this is what
happened so I don't look at her to
change the story I think that you know
he didn't want to
tell all the dirty stuff and then he got
being pushed in his character kept me in
question and then he said okay you want
to know what happened this is what
happened so I look at it more as you
know him trying to I can't say take the
high road because he didn't unserem
ceremoniously the way that he announced
but within that I would say that he
wasn't trying to put his foot on the
throat of the Lakers in any type of way
he had to come out and defend itself and
this is what we were hearing behind the
scenes anyway when he abruptly quitted
when he brought Lee quit so it made it
made sense but everybody's culpable a
but again the fact remains you hired
Frank Vogel to be the head coach and
that fact remains he is not better than
tyloo everybody talks about tyloo as if
he did not win a championship
that's what's hilarious to me everyone
acts like he can't coach because he won
a championship for LeBron well who else
wanted championship for LeBron people
don't talk about supposed to like that
and he had LeBron D Wade and Shaq
Almighty and then so he's a great coach
and I think that he should have been
considered and I think that more free
agents listen and like tyloo than the
media I think it's the media that
doesn't really respect his coaching
acumen and I think it you know it was a
mistake not to hire him because if you
don't win a championship in these three
years this whole project has been a
mistake
and how would you hire a coach that
never won a championship so when it's
championship with the guy that won a
championship and it's a last desperate
play I don't get it and last one for you
Chris
you know I would be remiss if I didn't
ask my Wolverine friend who you think
would be best for the job that b-line
suddenly left vacant at Michigan do you
have a thought on the subject yeah well
I'm telling my phone went off last night
and I'm very uncomfortable because I've
you know I you know you hear rumors if
someone already being hired and I know
Jim was gonna interview today but just
just let me tell you a little bit about
someone he's the first professional that
I ever met in my life that wasn't
a grown-up he's been a professional
since he's been young one of the hardest
workers he's the first NBA player and if
I'm not mistaken that graduated on time
but left early for the NBA coming out
his junior year he's been under one of
the best basketball minds ever over the
last ten years and that man his name is
Pat Riley he's worked with some of the
best players he's won a championship and
he's played with the best the best
players such as LeBron D Wade and others
respect him I don't know
first of all coach beeline was a hell of
a coach and I wonder what went on there
to make him quit so abruptly like magic
but he was a heck of a coach and we
really didn't get any recruits not one
McDonald's all-american and so to assume
that another coach can come in there and
recruit number one coaches well coach as
well as Dean line that's going to be
tough and then number two to recruit and
the out recruit is Oh coach Kay and
others that take the talent from the
Detroit area from the Michigan area in
my opinion I was very close with Bo
Schembechler in my opinion this is a
Michigan man and of course I'm biased
but I'm also biased because if my son
were lucky enough to get a scholarship
and it was between JaJuan and the greats
I would have him go there not because
your ma was my friend but because I know
the talks that he would have with my son
when I wasn't there I know I know he
would help him to be a man he would help
him to be accountable I know he would
work his butt off harder than any other
coach would and I know his compassion
the day that he signed in Michigan he
lost his grandmother and how important
she was to him and so I look at the
total man Juwan I look at the passion I
tell you this I know that he would love
for his house to be on State Street that
he would live on campus and he would
stay there and retire an old man I know
I know
that that's what he wants I know that
there's no other job in the world that
he would want more than that I know
there's nothing he would put his soul
into more than his wife and his kids in
that job and so when you talk about guys
bleeding maize and blue
that actually went there you know I know
coaches can come and adopt in and be
part of a culture but uh if all things
being equal it's about the guy that that
lived in the dorms and went to class and
lived in South quad and had the snowball
fights with West West quadrant that
knows the tradition and you don't have
to explain anything to them and it's not
about the fat 5 getting back together
even though of course you already know
we'd be there every second every game
you got there you know you know kick us
out from chairman telling us to quit
cheering so loud but it's also about the
Glen Rice is the real Robinson's the
Mark Hughes it's about the classes that
came before that as well how they
embrace JaJuan and I just think it would
be it would be a great galvanized ER for
everyone and and forgive me if that's
the problem and it forgive me it will
galvanize everyone else and put you know
everyone together and so uh I just know
the man is and more importantly I know
that I know that there's nothing more in
the world that he would want you know
he's been waiting for this opportunity
and so you're placed a guy like Dean
line you better you better have all your
box the addict and I think he would you
better come correct well I'm galvanized
and I say on behalf of me and every
single Michigan person I know of plus
one Chris Webber plus one on that
subject
Thanks the call Chris really appreciate
it loving your call with Marv as always
I thank you so much Chris always
appreciate dude all right but you gotta
ask Chris Webber at real corner for more
of the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 under red TV for free on VR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app